what you doing Katie oh
thanks
God okay Katy Perry breaks down in tears
on American Idol after a contestant
opens up about surviving a school
shooting we support them we nurture them
during Sunday night's episode Trey Lewis
a 21 year old mattress salesman from
Santa Fe Texas kicked things off with a
performance of stone by Whiskey Myers
they say Jesus was a poor man
I guess I wish I had a little more him
in me but when Luke Bryan asked why Trey
was auditioning for the show things took
a serious turn May 2018
um a gunman walked into my school
uh
I was in art room one
he shot up art room two
before he made his way to art room one
uh lost a lot of friends
uh eight eight students were killed uh
two teachers were killed
and while Luke praised Trey's vocal
skills Katie broke down in tears after
hearing his story you should be singing
here because you love music
because you have to go through them
you didn't have to lose eight friends
I hope that you remind people that we
have to change because you know
we have tolerated this for so long and
we've got to change true
I agree and I hope you can just lead as
for Trey's performance the decision was
unanimous
you're going to Hollywood let's go I
think actually what but we've been doing
season after season season is building
trust with the audience building trust
with
um the you know the trying to make it
artists out there we give them
constructive criticism we just like
teach them everything we know in all of
our years and even if they don't win
American Idol they go home just like
full of so much hope after the audition
aired Luke tweeted that Trey has the
perfect voice he complimented the way
Trey sings from the heart and said the
judges feel blessed he came on the show
quote no child should have to live
through what you did thank you for
sharing your positivity with us and the
world
[Music]
a million times